monsieur le ministre bonsoir bonsoir le
gouvernement va présenter la candidature
de la yole ronde de martinique au
patrimoine culturel immatériel de
l'unesco la décision sera connue fin
2020 d'ici là il faut convaincre les 23
pays qui vont voter avec la france ça
suppose aussi un peu de lobbying
je te donne l'unesco tu me donnes l'onu
quelle sera votre stratégie
justement pour défendre la yole martinez
alors non c'est pas comme ça je te donne
le flou ville dans les relations
bilatérales non parce que ce qui compte
c'est le dossier c'est le projet et ce
projet de laguiole martiniquaise c'est
un très bon projet préparé depuis huit
ans par des bénévoles des violeurs tout
des élus toute une communauté qui a
envie d'avoir le laguiole martiniquaise
reconnu sauf que comme patrimoine
culturel immatériel de l'humanité
c'est évidemment formidable mais la
france fait le choix d'un dossier est
donc avait mobilisé toute son énergie
pour ce dossier
et ça passe par la continuation de cette
défense très forte par les martiniquais
de laguiole mais aussi de toute la
communauté nationale
c'est la raison pour laquelle laquelle
le prix de la république sur ma
proposition est en lien avec angie rare
dans la mise d outre-mer a choisi ce
dossier là parce qu'il ya une adhésion
de la communauté martiniquaise et plus
largement nationale autour de ce projet
parce que c'est une tradition parce que
c'est une technologie une technique de
construction
et puis parce que c'est un une fête
aussi la yole fameuse course de viol
dont on parle tant j'ai fait un peu
violent hier à peine j'étais arrivée en
martinique que j'ai fait un peu de viol
et j'ai vu à quel point c'était aussi
une activité d' équipe il ya des valeurs
qui sont véhiculées par la yole qui sont
des belles valeurs et qui j'en suis
certain seront reconnus par l'unesco
donc le fait que la france ait choisi un
dossier et celui là de cette qualité là
je pense d'une façon très raisonnable
devrait nous permettre de l'emporter
on va parler également de france rô le
gouvernement donc l'annoncé la
suppression de la diffusion hertzienne
de cette chaîne beaucoup sont inquiets
pour la visibilité de nos territoires
dans l'hexagone vous répondez que c'est
une chaîne alibi que vous allez replacer
l'autre mer au centre et non plus à la
périphérie de l'audiovisuel public mais
expliquez moi comment vous
et par exemple convaincre franche de de
parler de nous autrement que pour des
cyclones ou pour l'enterrement de johnny
hallyday mais ça sera dans le cahier des
charges vous savez que entre l'état
entre les pouvoirs publics validé par le
parlement et l'audiovisuel public
notamment france télévisions
il ya un contrat d'objectif et moyens et
dans lequel il ya un cahier des charges
qui précise quelles sont les missions de
service public
est ce qu'on attend de ses missions de
service public par france télévisions et
il faudra bien définir ce qu'on attend
et on attend beaucoup en matière de
présence de l'audiovisuel public tant
dans les visages que dans les contenus
que dans l'information quels que soient
les antennes de france télévisions et il
faudra s'assurer que c'est bien
satisfait que les engagements pris
soient tenus
alors il ya un groupe de travail des
parlementaires avec les services de mon
ministère qui travaillent à cette
définition en lien bien évidemment avec
france télévisions qui a déjà commencé à
faire un somme de choses dans la matière
mais je crois vraiment que la présence
de deux loutres des outre-mer dans
l'audiovisuel public est indispensable
et ça passe par les outre-mer 1ère et
vous ce que vous démontrez ici en
martinique notamment est exemplaire est
aussi sur toutes les antennes nationales
que ce soit france 2 france 3 france 5
france info et donc je crois vraiment là
que il s'agit pas de laisser l'outre-mer
dans france ô il s'agit de mettre
l'outre-mer partout la visite est donc
de l'autre main passe aussi par la
musique en avril 2018 le trompettiste
guadeloupéen franck nicolas fait une
grève de la faim pour dénoncer l'absence
de gaz afro-caribéens sur les scènes
nationales d'une façon générale les
musiciens antillais s'estime boycotté
par les festivals et par les radios que
comptez vous faire pour changer cela et
bien j'ai pris la décision
j'ai proposé au premier ministre a pris
la décision de créer le centre national
de la musique le centre national de la
musique c'est un très beau projet qui
vise à rassembler un certain nombre
d'organismes qui existe déjà de soutien
aux nouveaux talents de soutien aux
couleurs de musique aux différents types
de musique par exemple jazz et ce centre
national de la musique va permettre
qu'on soit beaucoup plus efficace pour
soutenir justement des types de musique
qui sont un peu plus confidentielles
alors qu'ils devraient pas l'être ou qui
sont pas suffisamment exposés ou
diffuser et donc ce centre national
musique verra jour 1er janvier 2020 aura
comme obligation dans son cahier des
charges de mieux exposer la diversité de
la production musicale dans notre pays
et donc de notre pays dans sa diversité
et c'est ça qui devrait permettre de
mieux répondre aux aspirations bien
légitime des musiciens comme vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure et justement
quand on vit sur une île on vit plus
difficilement de sa musique avec les
disques qui se vante de deux mois - et
puis les spectacles qui se raréfie nos
musiciens ont quelquefois du mal à
joindre les deux bouts il demande au
gouvernement un allègement des charges
sociales pour les employeurs qui
embauchent des artistes outre mer qu'est
ce que vous leur répondez je leur
réponds que il ya un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui existent et je travaille
j'ai lancé une mission pour travailler
sur le statut des artistes auteurs donc
dans leur diversité les artistes auteurs
écrivains plasticiens et musiciens et
donc on va vraiment travaillé sur
comment aujourd'hui et demain dans notre
société donc encore une fois dans sa
diversité notamment les autres mais on
peut vivre de son art quand on est un
artiste auteur et puis il ya
deuxièmement tout ce qui concerne
l'intermittence vous savez qu'il ya une
réforme au niveau national de
l'assurance chômage le gouvernement dans
une annexe de 8 et 10 a souhaité ne pas
modifier les accords de 2016 et
s'assurer d'abord que ce qui a été
décidé puisse aller à son terme avant de
vouloir tout renégocier
c'est une engagement fort du
gouvernement vers l'intermittence qui
permet d'avoir un régime spécifique pour
les techniciens ou pour celles et ceux
qui travaillent dans le spectacle
juste pour l'audio visuel puisque vous
parlez dans des intermittents on aborde
un peu la question du cinéma avec la
martinique vous le savez qui s'est dotée
d'un bureau d'accueil des tournages
c'est une très bonne chose mais
justement pour les intermittents
le problème n'est toujours pas réglé on
exige d'eux le même nombre d'heures que
leurs collègues de l'hexagone
ça sent cette heure annuels alors qu'on
tourne beaucoup moins de films ici chez
nous est ce que c'est le système
pourrait changer
mais oui il faut que ça change il faut
qu'on ait davantage de production dans
l'eau dans les outre-mer et notamment en
martinique
on en parlait tout à l'heure avec les
équipes que j'ai rencontré de martinique
première pour dire il faut qu'ils aient
davantage de production en interne
production faite par martine pour rien
mais aussi par des producteurs
indépendants et ses productions
elle pourrait retrouver diffusion dans
les antennes de france télévisions
davantage et puis plus largement qu'il y
ait davantage de productions pas
simplement de deux lieux publics mais de
producteurs français ou européens qu'ils
se fassent en outre-mer il ya un
potentiel exceptionnel
il faut le développer pour que les
intermittents qui travaillent dans ces
métiers là puissent avoir davantage de
possibles au débat et au delà de il faut
qu est ce qui sera fait concrètement et
bien concrètement ça fera partie du
cahier des charges qui est en discussion
de france télévisions ça fera partie du
plan d'action du dire et c'est parfait
fait partie du plan d'action du
directeur de l'action culturelle ici en
martinique qui étaient nommés depuis un
mois et ça fait partie des priorités du
cnc qui vous savez
l'organisme qui vient abonder qui vient
financer aider au financement plus
exactement de production
cinématographique et audiovisuelle
une dernière question liée à l'actualité
la nouvelle secrétaire d'état et porte
parole du gouvernement si bête ndiaye
est la cible d'attaqués racistes depuis
sa nomination
pas un mot du gouvernement elle se
défend quasiment seul dans les médias
c'est un contraste saisissant avec la
réaction vigoureuse et rapide des
manuels macron lorsque alain
finkielkraut était insulté en février
dernier y aurait-il deux poids deux
mesures en lutte contre le racisme au
sommet de l'état non non pas du tout il
ya une détermination totale de la
secrétaire d'état en charge de la lutte
contre les discriminations
et pour l'égalité a mode mon âme
arrivants s'y attendait le gouvernement
est très mobilisé sur la lutte contre
toute forme de discrimination toute
forme de racisme toute forme
d'antisémitisme de toute forme
d'homophobie toute forme de
discrimination et je suis et le
gouvernement est mobilisé contre tous et
dans le cas de sylvain n'diaye on n'a
pas entendu ni emmanuel macron ni vous
dit quelque chose soit volé à son
secours
d'abord vous assurez la connaissant bien
elle est très déterminée elle a pas
spécialement besoin qu'on vole à son
secours mais elle a besoin
nous avons besoin dans notre pays ne me
disais contre ces discriminations et le
croyez moi dans l'action que je mène au
sein du ministère et dans la parole qui
est la mienne régulièrement je suis
premier avec mes collègues du
gouvernement à lutter avec force contre
ces discriminations et notamment le
racisme
franck reste un merci merci beaucoup